we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
our next caller comes to us today from
the 702 area code caller what's your
name and where are you calling from
hi my name is Ashton I'm calling from
Reno Nevada
ok great what's on your mind today ok
first thing I want to say thank you as a
college student is hard to stay
up-to-date with the news and you guys
don't miss job being a busy access to
like people who don't have easy access
to news so just thank you for that for
as well I wanted to address the American
healthcare act I saw that potentially
they could be in the past and after
converting to Republicans to get to vote
so do you know anything about the
coverage for mental health in there
because I know specifically about the
rising adolescent population that
engages in like self interest behavior
like cutting fasting and even like
suicide rates among adolescents have
gone up and didn't understand the
coverage like a dead bat would swing for
that kind of stuff no never network is
difficult being mental health coverage
is not going to be you know but we talk
about the essential health benefit to
sort of minimum that every insurance
they need to cover and often on that
sometimes it's it's a vaccination well
visits to your primary care physician or
you know whether birth control should be
included in there but mental health
coverage at least as far as I know Pat
is not typically mentioned as sort of
like one of these it's got to be there
and it needs to mostly be covered by
insurance I mean my guess is that
American Health Care Act revision or not
you're going to see mental health
services sort of covered with a copay
and or after meeting a deductible like
many services right we haven't heard
anything specifically as it pertains to
the mental health care when it comes to
the American Health Care Act now I'd
like to see I haven't seen anything
either hey I out of curiosity are you
like a are you in a workshop or building
building something out of wood or so
like that there's very unusual noises in
the background there I'm actually just
in the library at my school some stuff
around sorry about that the library is
not where you would imagine BOM I would
be noise no yeah that's odd sorry about
that I also just wanted to bring up the
idea that May is actually mental health
awareness month yeah and yeah I think I
know the host important I'm a psychology
guy so we study that a lot but I mean
you wouldn't get mad at someone for
having cancer telling them to get over
it not giving them the proper coverage
so I don't understand why someone with
like depression or schizophrenia and all
this kind of stuff is treated
differently so I just wanted to bring
attention to that I agree with you I
agree with you the way in which mental
health is stigmatized is something I've
been speaking out about for many many
years and you know but so many people in
my family are in the mental health
community as service providers and
you're absolutely spot-on and I
appreciate you making that point so
thanks so much for giving us a call I
really really appreciate it on that note
let's pause we will go to a break we
still have a few more callers we're
going to hear from after the break stay
with us